With a sneaky villainous twist and a cliffhanger
ending to set up Season 2, Jenna Ortega's
gloriously deadpan take on Wednesday Addams
is plenty of fun!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm breaking down the ending
of Wednesday Season 1 and revealing the hidden
clues to the mystery that even Wednesday herself
missed.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
The puppet master at the heart of the first
season's whodunit is Miss Thornhill, Nevermore's
resident dorm mum and botany teacher, whose
real name is actually Laurel Gates.
Although Wednesday doesn't realise that Thornhill's
the secret villain until Eugene says he saw
red boots on the person who set the cave on
fire, as viewers we should have been suspicious
of her when she introduced herself for the
first time.
Good evening, girls.
Oh, sorry about the mud.
In the scene shortly before this, we'd seen
the sheriff and his deputy in the woods in
the rain, surveying the crime scene of the
hiker killed by the monster.
So, when Miss Thornhill stamps her muddy boots
while claiming she's only been in her conservatory,
it's a clue that she'd likely been outside
in the woods near the murder scene instead.
All of Thornhill's connections with dangerous
plants were hinted at right in the opening
episode when we saw her smiling as she fed
live worms to some Venus fly traps.
Wednesday later deduces that after Thornhill
revealed to Tyler the family secret that his
own mother was a Hyde, she used extracts from
her plants to fully unlock the Hyde inside
him.
But well before Wednesday figured that out,
there were several clues to Miss Thornhill's
interest in botanical chemical trickery.
Most plants reward their pollinators with
sweet nectar, many carnivorous varieties turn
to sexual trickery or deception.
And the way that Hydes effectively become
slaves to those who unlock their power…
This act causes the Hyde to develop an immediate
bond with its liberator, who the creature
now sees as its master.
… was also hinted at when Thornhill explained
another trick from the plant world.
The orchid produces a pheromone that mimics
a female insect, luring the males in.
Thornhill even gives herself away a little
right at the very end, when just before Wednesday's
expelled, she gives her an oleander plant
as a parting gift, which as Wednesday observed
is especially toxic.
White oleander.
One of nature's deadliest.
The body parts that Thornhill collects and
stores in jars are part of her plan to resurrect
her ancestor and original zealot Joseph Crackstone.
And there's a little clue to this earlier
on when she presents Wednesday with a copy
of the classic novel Frankenstein by Mary
Shelley.
Similar to how Thornhill brings to life the
monstrous Crackstone with a spell that conducts
electricity between the body parts she'd been
collecting, in Shelley's novel Victor Frankenstein's
monster was created from a collection of animal
and human pieces.
And the idea of electricity bringing Frankenstein's
creature to life became popularised after
the 1931 movie.
When Crackstone is mentioned for the first
time as Jericho's founding father, a couple
of banners for Pilgrim World are unveiled
with the words "Where History Comes To Life"
together with a picture of the long-dead pilgrim,
in a clever bit of foreshadowing and a hint
to his resurrection in the final episode.
And just after Wednesday breaks into the old
meeting house and comes across a model of
the evil pilgrim, she narrates…
Secrets are like zombies…
they never truly die.
… which is another nice bit of foreshadowing
for how Crackstone can and will come back
as a kind living dead creature himself.
And Crackstone's death at Wednesday's hands,
which sees him burning up into a cloud of
hot ash and smoke, was also telegraphed earlier
in the season when she and Thing set the memorial
statue of him on fire and the metal melted
into a black goo.
Now, Wednesday Addams may be full of woe,
but thanks to the sponsor of this video, Kamikoto
Knives, you'll never have to suffer using
a blunt blade again when you're preparing
your next meal.
I got this fantastic trio of blades made with
high quality Japanese Steel for my partner,
and he loves the way they slice easily through
tough ginger root, butternut squash, pineapple,
and all types of fruit and veggies.
Each blade is hand-crafted using techniques
perfected across generations of knife smiths,
and Michelin star chefs all over the world
use Kamikoto.
The blades have an incredibly sharp edge that
slices through meat or fish like butter, and
getting these thin slices of sashimi is so
easy.
The knives will make an amazing gift this
holiday season as they come in a beautiful
ash wood presentation box.
Plus each blade is individually inspected
and comes with a lifetime guarantee.
Kamikoto has a special Black Friday Sale on
right now and all our viewers can get an extra
50 dollars off with discount code FLICK50.
So, go to kamikoto.com/FLICK50 to get your
Kamikoto Japanese steel knives today.
Wednesday prefers to do things alone.
I'll survive alone.
I always have.
However, in the end, taking down the villainous
trio of Laurel, the Hyde and Crackstone was
something Wednesday simply couldn't do by
herself;
instead it required a team effort.
This was predicted early on when she met Eugene
for the first time and he explained why he
liked bees so much.
They're nature's perfect community.
All working together to achieve a common goal.
So, although Wednesday confronts Tyler alone,
it's one of her friends, Enid after wolfing
out who saves her just before he's about to
kill her.
Then when Wednesday tries to take down the
evil Crackstone, the villain smashes her sword
to pieces with his magical staff and is about
to finish her off, but Bianca stabs him from
behind, which gives Wednesday just enough
time to grab a shard of the sword and this
time she stabs him in the heart, which as
her ancestor Goody explained…
Crackstone must be stabbed through his black
heart.
It is the only way he will be vanquished now
and forever.
After Crackstone's demise, Laurel decides
to kill Wednesday herself, but this time it's
her friend Eugene who stops Laurel when he
turns up with his bees.
Wednesday's my only friend, and if she's in
trouble, I've got to help her.
It's hive code.
By the way, Wednesday taking an arrow to the
shoulder to save Xavier from Crackstone, mirrors
how he saved her from the falling gargoyle
in the first episode.
The last few moments of the finale leave us
with some big questions for a potential Season
2, such as who is the mystery stalker sending
threatening texts to Wednesday?
Someone who might be antagonistic towards
her is the Siren guy, Kent.
He was in charge of sabotaging the other teams
during the Poe Cup race, however both Wednesday's
net and Thing's punch to the face stopped
him, and he ended up getting the blame for
queen bee Bianca losing.
It was your job to help us win and she's never
lost.
Wednesday also made him look foolish in front
of the other Nightshades when she explained
how she'd discovered their secret meeting
room.
Then I solved the riddle.
Wait, there's a riddle?
I thought we just snapped twice.
Well, aren't you the brightest in the bunch?
Seriously, even Kent is here?
How exclusive is this club?
Alternately, it might be someone connected
to the MorningSong cult run by Bianca's mum.
It seemed like a weird subplot when this came
up, and I wonder whether it'll be explored
further in Season 2.
We are a personal development movement that
helps people take control of their lives.
After you take control of their bank account.
Another possibility could be the mayor's son
Lucas, who got interested in MorningSong via
a self-help app that Bianca's mum recommended
to him.
His father was killed, presumably by Laurel.
And although he appears to regret the Carrie-style
stunt at the Rave'N, he and his two mates
do have an antagonistic history with Wednesday
when she fought them after they harassed her
at the coffee shop.
And the final shot of Season 1 has Tyler Hulking
out –
or, rather, Hyding out –
which makes me wonder if Laurel is actually
dead, or whether she's still alive and able
to trigger him to transform into a Hyde.
She may still have some kind of connection
with Tyler, and so after he presumably breaks
out of the truck, he could go and find her
and together they could plot their revenge
on Wednesday.
So, who do you think Wednesday's stalker could
be?
And is Principal Weems really dead?
Comment with any thoughts, plus Season 2 theories
below!
Tap here for my next Netflix video, and if
you enjoyed this video, do leave a thumbs-up,
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying Wednesday with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!